Today we will continue our discussion
of pre contractual reliance based
liability.
You might remember from our last class
discussing the Hoffman v Red Owl case.
That liability may be appropriate if
one party repeatedly Bates and switches
during negotiation and the other
party relies to its detriment.
Today we will see a more modern
application of this idea in Dixon,
the wells Fargo Bank.
Despite being a fairly recent case,
Judge Young's opinion includes one of
the most careful discussions of the
development of promissory Estoppel
and the literature on pre contractual
negotiations.
Before we start,
let's take a moment to understand
the basics of a mortgage.
A mortgage or a mortgage loan is
used by home buyers to purchase the,
to purchase homes.
The lender is usually a bank credit
union or other financial institution.
These loans are usually secured on the,
uh,
with the security security
being the borrower's property.
This means that if the borrower
defaults or is unable to pay, uh,
the loan as it comes due,
the lender can start
foreclosure proceedings,
which ultimately can lead to a foreclosure
sale where the proceeds from the sale
or first used to pay off the debt
and only the remainder if any.
Uh, it goes to the debtor. By the way,
the homeowner is the one mortgaging
the property and so it was called the
mortgage or,
and then bank is the mortgagee.
A mortgage is a contract with a set of
terms that binds both the lender and the
borrower. The terms of the
contractor sometimes modified.
This process is known as a
loan modification, sometimes
as a debt restructuring.
Of course,
both the lender and the borrower have
to agree to the modification for the
modification to be effective while
people modify their loans for a number of
reasons.
One common reason is for a change
in the borrower's ability to pay.
For instance, if someone loses
their job or a spouse becomes sick,
a borrower might want to modify the loan
terms to make sure he or she doesn't
default.
As you can imagine,
a home purchase is often quite expensive
and most people did not have enough
cash on hand to pay the whole
price of the home. That's,
that's why they borrow money.
Mortgages are therefore very common
and many of you may already have one or
we'll have one soon.
When functioning properly,
mortgages are essential to the wellbeing
of the economy and the real estate
market.
However,
things sometimes go awry during
the subprime mortgage crisis,
which contributed to the US and world
recession from 2007 through 2009 a decline
in home prices caused a large number of
homeowners to default and led to massive
mortgage foreclosures.
The effects rattled the U S and world
economies and we're still still feeling
some of those effects today. The, uh,
events in the Dixon case happen during
this turbulent time in the u s economy in
June,
2009,
the plaintiff's Dixon's orally agreed
with the defendant's well Fargo to take
steps to enter in to a mortgage
loan modification negotiations,
including stopping payments
on their mortgage and
submitting requested financial
information. The plaintiff's
perform these, perform these steps.
But the defendants failed to enter the
modification negotiations in December,
2010 plaintiffs received notice that
defendant was foreclosing based on the
borrower's failure to make
mortgage payments even
though the borrower failed to
make payments be at the request of wells
Fargo as a precondition of going into a
modification negotiation.
Yeah,
the plaintiffs initiated suit in
state court seeking number one,
an injunction prohibiting defendant from
foreclosing on their home and number
two specific performance of
an oral agreement to enter
into loan modifications.
And number three, seeking damages.
The defendant, Wells Fargo,
removed the case to federal
court and then move to dismiss.
How can you make an argument
that promissory Estoppel
liability as appropriate
under these alleged facts?
Well,
promissory Estoppel again allows for
enforcing the promise even if made without
formal consideration.
When the promise see relies on the
promise to her detriment. In this case,
the promise,
the promise.
See was the borrower who relied on
the bank's promise to enter in to
modification negotiations.
If the borrowers would stop
making their monthly payments,
the borrower's reliance was to their
detriment because the bank subsequently
foreclosed on their home.
Yeah.
The main issue in this case is whether
promissory representations in preliminary
negotiations give rise to pre contractual
liability when the promise he acts in
reasonable Lee foreseeable reliance upon
those representations or promises to
their detriment.
Okay,
let's break it down to
make sure we understand the
promises or the problem story
representation in this case is the
banks offer to enter into a loan
modifications.
The negotiations are preliminary because
they're not negotiating the of the
modification. The liability in
this case would be pre contractual.
Since we can consider the modified
loan to be a new contract,
the liability is for the borrowers
reliance made prior to any actual loan
modification.
The promise.
See in this case the borrower's relied
on the banks promissory representation by
stopping, uh, uh, making payments and,
and by submitting the requested
financial information,
this was to their detriment because again,
the bank turned around and foreclosed on
their home for failure to make payments.
Thus, another way to frame this issue
is simply whether promissory Estoppel is
available for pre contractual promises.
In this case,
the court held that yes,
promissory Estoppel is available for
pre contractual promises. This is true.
Even though all the other
elements of contractual liability,
we're not made out such as
sufficient definiteness.
Is this case a new red l?
Well,
in our last lesson we learned
about the holding and red owl,
which will also allowed for pre
contractual reliance spaced liability.
When read Al was decided there was
thought there was a thought that it was an
application of promissory Estoppel in
the pre contractual setting that might
point the way toward a more
general obligation of good
faith in pre contractual
negotiations.
That potential was not realized as
red owl has not had a broad effect.
In some ways the Dixon case though
shows that Red Al is not dead yet.
It can still have important implications
in certain current circumstances.
Also recall teachers insurance, uh, uh,
by Judge Laval that we
discussed in the last case. Uh,
and it's line of
preliminary agreement cases,
the teachers insurance case adopted and
intent based test for when parties have
entered into a preliminary
agreement to negotiate.
The key inquiry query was whether the
parties intended for their commitment to
negotiate to be binding.
Judge young was clearly aware of the
teachers case and that line of cases.
Is there a reason he did not apply
them to the Dixon case itself? Well,
one reason may be that the intent based
inquiry would not generate the result of
liability that judge young wanted.
Uh,
this intent based inquiry created a
strong presumption against finding binding
obligations in agreements to negotiate.
It might make more sense for sophisticated
parties who understand what the law
is and understand the each other.
Here the bank has a lot more information
than the plaintiff borrowers who are
are struggling to understand
the terms of the loan.
This might be one reason for why judge
young opted for promissory Estoppel in
this case.
This example also might be a,
an example of crisis law.
During Times of war or
economic or political crisis,
courts might decide cases differently
than they would during non crisis times.
What law is being applied in this case,
state or federal?
The answer is State Law.
Notice that while this is a federal court,
most of the citations are
to Massachusetts cases.
Much contemporary law
regarding pre contractual
liability has been developed by
federal courts,
by federal judges applying
state law teachers.
Insurance is especially
noteworthy in this regard. First,
it ran against the spirit
of New York state law cases,
uh,
cases decided by New York state courts,
which schlock sharply limited pre
contractual liability. And second,
the broad ranging factual inquiry into
the party's intent differed from the
tendency of New York courts to put
greater weight on the written word in the
United States.
A federal court can pose a certified
question for an opinion on a question of
state law to assist or state court.
Not every state permits federal
courts to certify questions,
uh,
to their state courts.
But Massachusetts does in Dixon judge
young discuss this possibility but
ultimately decided not to certify the
question whether the Dixons allegations
are sufficient to state a claim for
promissory Estoppel to the judicial court,
which is the highest
court in Massachusetts.
Though the judge leaves
open the possibility for
certification if wells Fargo or
the Dixon files a motion for him to do so.
Whether federal courts should be more
willing to certify undecided state law
questions to state courts
is an interesting problem.
On the one hand,
certification might reduce inconsistency
in application of state law and give
states better control
over what their law is.
On the other hand,
it might slow the wheels of justice.
Today we examine Dixon versus wells Fargo,
a case that held promissory
representations in pre
contractual note negotiations
can be enough to establish
reliance based liability.
It is a modern application of red owl,
which we learned in just the last class.
The case also stands for the proposition
that reliance based liability rather
than the more exacting intent-based
inquiry inquiry and teachers assurance is
sometimes going to be chosen,
at least during times of crisis.